something tells me that i should make a
little video about how i'm feeling
i'm really excited to get the implants
out in like 10 days
because number one my hair sucks
remember that long dark beautiful hair
no mas the reason why i cut it short was
just because it was not as healthy it
just seemed like oh it's just not as
nice let's just start over
it just doesn't want to grow back now
and it's not that thick and
one of the main symptoms of bii
is hair thinning and losing your hair so
that's nice
another is thyroid
after a year of three different doctors
three different medicines
six or so different doses
can't get that right can't get the can
get the dosage right my thyroid is still
not
functioning at the way it should which
is kind of the gateway to your
metabolism so
you know weight gain has been super
frustrating and weight loss has been
nearly impossible
um
i mean i did a five day cleanse and lost
zero weight not even water weight so
very very frustrating
i think the short-term memory loss stuff
is a real thing and i think energy too i
mean i just have such a strong mindset
that it's hard for me to
like just sit around but i have to will
myself kind of every day i guess that's
something i've never put together like
it's not just natural bubbly energy it's
just
a will to like not sit around and do
something go work out go do this stay
busy stay moving around
so it's not really supernatural it's not
just like there and ready to go i i will
it so um and recovery from workouts has
been crap and then there's all kinds of
other markers like testosterone dhea
vitamin d
magnesium
estrogen progesterone like literally all
my hormones everything's just low
like it just
it's kind of just like shut down city
[Music]
i want to describe my symptoms first
because
for those watching that are interested i
think this is the most important thing
to start off with so
i'm gonna go down the list and then
we'll hit on the big ones the shape of
my face and swelling woolen lymph nodes
in my neck
my hair was thinning and breaking off
dry scalp and dry skin weird underarm
smell sometimes just like one armpit not
the other
recovering from workouts and
training for the boston marathon i mean
i needed two days to recover and the
girls that did it with me were ready to
go like that night so recovery was
terrible uh general fatigue not extreme
but definitely like laboring through my
days and not feeling kind of that
normal kind of bubbly energy heavy metal
toxicity which was tested from
with a provoked urine test leaky gut
also tested dysbiosis also tested 10 out
of 10 dysbiosis hypothyroidism so that
was kind of the first thing that came
along for me was i was like oh my god
this is the answer to everything my
thyroid is low
that was
just scratching the surface weight gain
and resistance to weight loss like
nothing i did made a difference for
years and years like four years or more
capsular contracture i mean that's just
a side effect of the implants um
so you have the implant and then your
tissues form a capsule around it when
there's blood or rupture that makes it
even more
um
it makes a thicker capsule around it
uh and so i actually thought that
crashing race cars maybe was doing that
and so i had it tested and it wasn't and
then the other one did it after i was
done racing so that wasn't it it was
just my body producing
tissue to protect myself and the
implants were folded within the within
the capsule so they were
really uh tight elevated crp which is
just an inflammatory marker low
testosterone low vitamin d low dhea low
estrogen low progesterone low white
blood cell count low magnesium
uh all those were tested with blood
tests um
and urine and saliva and all the things
adrenal fatigue so this was done through
a urine test but my you normally wake up
and your cortisol goes up and mine
spiked in the middle of the night
probably from
um hypoglycemia and then it just kept
going down all day so that's kind of
indicative of your adrenals not
functioning properly and and giving your
cortisol a rise so adrenal fatigue
dizziness i've noticed that like my
dizziness is better so i i it kind of
was there before but
dizziness standing up temperature
sensitivity just like being too hot or
too cold all the time
every now and again so some people have
really bad achy hands and achy joints
but um my hands kind of did it a few
times to me and i'm like what is this
this feels like arthritis
uh but it wasn't constant um and then
maybe some short-term memory stuff like
talking to somebody and just forgetting
what i was going to ask them like i
don't know if that's normal or not
probably not
so those are my symptoms there are
others for those watching that are
curious there's
the big hitters that i didn't mention
that i had because i watched over a
hundred at least 100 women's stories
through instagram youtube a lot of them
also had brain fog anxiety
and depression and extreme fatigue and
so i wouldn't say i had those but if
you're watching some people some people
do i just didn't manifest those i mean
now if we go back in the story because
look getting my implants out it wasn't
like i thought oh i'll get my implants
out and then i'll be better i only
started talking about it so quickly
after because i got better so fast like
within hours i could there was a
difference starting to happen but
everything i did along the way i thought
was the thing if we go back to
2018 my indicators were resistance to
weight loss like gained a few pounds and
couldn't get it off no matter what i did
no matter what i ate no matter how much
i worked out and looking back my hair
too like it just kept getting
less thick and healthy and long and
eventually that's kind of why i cut it
was because i thought well just not
healthy anymore maybe i'm just aging i
mean how many out there like think i'm
just aging and this is why so
i thought maybe i'm just getting older
my hair is not the same and so those
were kind of my two indicators that i
had about four years ago in 2018
and then fast forward to 2020
um
then i'd say another wave of weight gain
which was just punishing at the end of
2020 beginning 2021
i had my cycle was getting later and
later for a couple months and then i
skipped a couple months and i thought
i should probably go get this fixed and
honestly it was a godsend because i just
kept thinking i should just try harder i
should just try harder right
and so i went in and had a blood draw
and you know a bunch of lab work done i
thought nine vials was a lot when i got
my blood drawn that time oh my gosh fast
forward to later i ended up having like
19 drawn for um for my leaky gut test
but anyway so i got my blood drawn and
my thyroid was low i mean there was
other things too for sure but i thought
man that's it that's going to explain
weight gain that's going to explain
hair loss because that's another thing
from thyroid
dry skin dry scalp like those those okay
all of a sudden i'm like here we go and
i remember when the doctor gave me
thyroid pills for the first time and i
thought this is it this one little pill
and it was like a tiny little um dose of
um it was a natural desiccated pig
because you can either have synthetic or
desiccated pig and it was the desiccated
so it was a natural one and i thought oh
my god this is the solution and that
didn't do anything and then i doubled it
and i thought that will do it and then
that didn't do anything and then i added
more and then that didn't do anything
either and um so that was kind of just
starting the process at the beginning of
2021 that was about it was april of 2021
and from there my doctor said look
because he was just my my ob and so he's
like i think you should see a functional
doctor and i'm like okay so i managed to
get in with a functional doctor and in
the meantime i also um
i also was introduced to
ben greenfield's book boundless and i
thought wow this is fascinating and i
thought i should interview ben
greenfield and so ben greenfield is like
a biohacking guy and at the end of the
conversation i said if i wanted to know
like what to eat how to when to eat how
to work out when to work out what would
i do and he's like take these tests and
so i ordered all the tests and now i
understand i'm fortunate these tests are
not cheap and so i spent a ton of money
on tests i got all the tests then i
started working with the functional
doctor and so between the two of them i
realized that so many things were going
on the one really big one that popped up
was um heavy metal toxicity
and so i had insanely high mercury like
it has to be under five to be i think in
a tolerable range
a range that's not above the threshold
and mine was 170.
so i had insanely high mercury i also
had four other metals that were elevated
um above the threshold so um heavy metal
toxicity leaky gut i mean when i got the
results from my leaky gut i was like
what am i gonna eat like i mean cinnamon
was on it like everything was on it and
so i went on a 90-day gut protocol for
that where i
you know cut out all the things that
were high only a couple things that were
moderate here and there just because i
literally could only have like four
proteins and how much cod do you really
want to eat so i i had very a very
restricted diet for 90 days on top of
probably taking 20 to 30 pills a day
then
dysbiosis was another one that popped up
in the test the one thing about
dysbiosis i was a 7 out of 10 when we
first tested it then i was a 10 out of
10 when we tested it the next time and
so for those out there that do marathons
and heavy heavy training i i think
marathon training can make that a little
worse and i was training for the boston
marathon while i was doing all this so
um i'm gonna just stack it high and deep
but the dysbiosis got worse when we
retested it a second time so for the
heavy metals just so people know what
you really want to do is a provoked
urine test a provoked urine test is
where you
take a sample
first thing in the morning and then you
take
this drug
it's called dmsa and so i take all these
dmsa pills and then for the next six
hours you collect your urine and then
you make a sample out of it and
basically it pulls out of your body into
storage because it gets stored in fat
cells and all over the place in your
body so
that kind of gives you more of your
long-term load as opposed to just a
blood test as testing more recent yeah i
mean i went through all that i thought
thyroid medicine was going to be the
cure then i thought
leaky gut protocol for 90 days is going
to be the cure and then i thought
heavy metals infrared sauna sweating
getting that out and then eventually i
did chelation which is where you take
that dmsa but you do it every day
um for it was sort of a cycle it was
like five days on a couple days off or
something like that so i did chelation
to try and get rid of it too and i
thought i literally thought all of these
things were going gonna do it i thought
this is where i'm gonna feel better and
every single time i went to the doctor
and i said i don't feel any different i
don't look any different
nothing changed then i started working
with another doctor
at the beginning of 2022 um a great
doctor still working with him right now
ben greenfield introduced me to him i
started taking peptides and so i thought
this will be it i'll take peptides and
this is going to help me feel better and
look better
and i took peptides and i mean like for
someone like me like i hate needles and
the fact that i stuck myself with up to
three needles a day is really saying
something so took the peptides again
reported back with really don't feel any
different don't look any different um so
that didn't work either um
and uh the one good thing is we did cut
out a lot of pills when i went with the
doctor that i'm with now he's like just
stop taking it and stop stressing and
he's very much about mindset and and
being really positive and thinking
positive thoughts and so and to not be
overwhelmed by things so i did like that
a lot um we also tried new thyroid
medicine um so i tried thyroid medicine
from my ob a different thyroid medicine
with my functional doctor and then
another different thyroid medicine in
which i take a t3 t4 combo in the
morning and then two more times in the
day i just take t3 alone because t3 is
what is active in your body and goes
into every cell of your body and gives
and gives you the energy it's basically
i mean it's your metabolism it's
everything and so
i take it two more times in the day
and all of that
still doesn't make my t3 go up
so nothing works so if there's one thing
that i can say that i feel like i've
gathered from watching all these women's
stories my own story
is that
nothing works like the symptoms are all
over the place if you're gonna look up
breast implant illness and you're gonna
look at the symptoms
there's a hundred i mean there's there's
just anything but it's really just how
your body is going to manifest with
trying to get rid of something and is it
through inflammation and is it through
um fatigue are you going to is you're
gonna is you do you have gut issues is
your skin some people get rashes like
however you manifest is personal to you
but the main point is is that you can't
fix it and so i didn't go into getting
my
implants removed thinking
like oh this is the thing like i thought
everything was gonna be the thing and so
when i got them out
i mean first off i was really excited i
was over them they were hard they were
hard they had capsular contracture i was
ready woke up after anesthesia came home
and my mom said i came to pretty quick
so within like two hours i'm sitting on
the couch and i remember i put my hand
on my face and i was like oh my god mom
my skin is producing oil for the first
time my i have not felt like what it's
like to have like oil on my face i don't
remember the last time which is exactly
why my skin and my scalp have been dry
and so
my scalp isn't producing oil so it's dry
and then my hair goes to grow and it's
not getting any nourishment no moisture
and it's just breaking off before it has
a chance to get long and so and and i'm
sure thyroid and other things play a
factor too but it's like
oh my god i was so relieved to finally
realize like i have skin that produces
oil um then i woke up in the morning um
and i mean all i took for drugs was
i took a hydrocodone at
surgery was over with at 4 30.
um i took a hydrocodone about 9 30 p.m
another one at about 4 30 in the morning
when i woke up um managed to get back to
sleep for a little bit and then i took a
tylenol at noon and i took one more
tylenol at about 9 p.m before bed and
that's all i took so
you know minimal on the drugs
but i woke up in the morning after
surgery and i'm pacing around the
kitchen and i'm just like
i realize i'm pacing around the kitchen
i'm like mom i just have a lot of energy
and so the fact that i'm like fresh out
of surgery within 12 hours i'm still on
drugs to some degree and i just feel all
this energy we went grocery shopping and
you know we're doing our day went for a
walk with the dogs very easily from
there uh more things that changed was uh
my face i mean i think that was
something that people were following me
like my face looked different that night
and my face is changing every day and
the inflammation that's coming out of my
body like my clothes fit better like and
it's only been a week from the time i'm
recording this so
everything my lymph nodes in my neck
have gone down i mean
like
yeah i mean i this one they can barely
feel them they're barely sticking out
like
that was such a relief because i could
feel them every single day i could feel
them when i moved when i ate something
like they were just i could just feel it
and i just i just have been recovering
so quickly and so
this is a journey i'm i'm just i just
felt compelled to share i felt compelled
to
um tell people how much better i felt
and to let people know that you know if
you're struggling that they're
and you have implants like and you can't
fix it
there could be something wrong with them
like they could be making you sick
and
i just thought it was an important
message for people to know because i
tried so hard and i tried so many things
and usually that's the case i mean even
if you don't have as much time and
energy and
you know flexibility with money like i
mean most people try so many things and
um and so i just hope that
i hope that if you're out there and
you're struggling that you'll entertain
this idea and you'll start watching the
stories and let your intuition guide you
right like i i mean i
i did i i just i it like there was a
seed in my head that was like could this
be it and i'm so glad that i listened to
that you know your intuition is a really
powerful tool feel into that and i'll
keep sharing how it's going because this
is only one week post-op so like i'm
sure that things will change after
a month and six months and 12 months and
i have testing to do still i'm gonna
re-check re-test my gut and re-test the
heavy metals i'll retest um all my all
my blood markers for all my all my
endocrine system hormones i mean all
that stuff needs to be retested and i'll
share you know how quickly that changes
or slowly and out of the long list that
i started off with of what i've been
dealing with
i don't know if all of them are going to
be taken care of by getting the implants
out but i made the list to see just how
many can be checked off and
i'm
honored to share that journey so that i
can help others in their journey
themselves because it was through
watching them that i
felt not so crazy and
where the mission to get these out
really really sank in because i i saw so
many stories of women feeling better so
if you're struggling
i hope that you figure it out and if
this is it and i'm a part of it i'm
happy to go through it so i think it's
really important that we get
nitty-gritty details from a doctor so
i've asked my doctor sean parson if he
will come on here and he's going to sit
down with me and we're going to get into
some of the details and hear from his
perspective you know what he's seen in
his practice um what women's symptoms
are how they get better what the drug
companies are telling him like what does
he hear from his perspective so that we
can understand better what the doctors
are dealing with thank you so much for
sitting down and doing this absolutely
and also thank you for doing great
surgery on me
was i a tough patient
uh you no you weren't a tough but for me
you were you were fine i mean i was
asleep so not like that but like was my
operation a tough operation no i think
uh i think you're you're petite so it
was kind of taking it was like a reverse
uh
delivery of a baby
you know
well i i guess i guess delivery of a
baby you know not a reverse delivery of
a baby but you know
get it out going through you know a
larger object through a smaller little
spot as we can you can describe so i
mean we went through the nipple and like
reached so block and like explain go
ahead and explain like exactly what was
done so
so
years ago when you initially had your
original surgery the surgeon had chosen
to make a small incision on the lower
portion of your arula
and so rather than trying to make some
brand new
incision you know if at all possible i
want to try to
not make extra scars yeah i like that so
we
i went through the same so you kind of
go through the same scar come down um on
the on the implant
capsule the scar the scarred area so
kind of go through breast tissue get get
down on that and then
with with cautery you kind of asked me
earlier yeah i did i was i wanted to
kind of know the details just a little
bit like what happens in there so so
there's i mean some you know some
scissors but but cautery just so we you
know kind of caught our eyes as we go
and you just create a a plane
it would be
like um if you've kind of encased
something and say there's a little
marble and it's encased in
foam
and you want to you know go down and
then chip away all the foam but but not
just obviously just you know you want to
just take that one little marble out if
you can so
clean all that um sometimes it's more
attached to certain spots yours was a
little bit more attached to the muscle
so on the on the upper portion
it was attached to the breast tissue
underneath it was attached to the top of
the muscle so would you say that it was
more stuck more attached than
some other implants yeah
for sure and i think i think
you know think of it as your body's
trying to wall off that device yeah but
it's also the scars
not that smart so the scars the cigar is
also stuck to the area outside of it
as well as trying to wall off on the
inside i see
so it's just it's just really trying to
fixate and not let that thing go
anywhere
and the capsular contracture i mean you
know like i
i mean i went to cu for one that had
capsular contracture and i think it
popped up in like 2018 but i might have
seen you in 19 for it and then the other
one ended up doing it too and so
somebody asked me on social media if i
how do you know if you have capsular
contracture and i posted that video and
said you'll know right like you know so
maybe some indicators on that and then
also there are levels of it and i think
you said i was maybe like a two-three on
there is that yeah was that more like a
three once you got him out i think
you're a three for sure i think out of
four out of four yeah so so it's it's a
there's a it's basically more of a
subjective scale so if someone has an
implant
i don't know why when when it was set up
way back when it wasn't you know 0-10 or
0-5 but it seems like 0 should be
perfect but but one's
as if there's no implant in so there's
very little scar
two there's noticeably some um firmness
to the breast it may still look fairly
um aesthetically normal but but there's
there's firmness that you can feel and
maybe there's a difference between the
two sides three
really starts to kind of physically
distort the breast a little bit it's
it's more firm maybe the breast pulls up
but it's not
it's not the normal shape that had been
in the past right um four i mean can get
to the point where it's
you know
almost like a rock you know and they can
be painful too right yeah and even even
if they're not uh so firm if they start
to have components of pain
that automatically kicks you into the
floor so i noticed with mine that when i
push on it enough like it because
they're firm
you know if i pushed on it it would be
sore it felt kind of like achy sore yeah
but if i didn't push on it didn't hurt
right um so maybe that's also another
tool that you know
people can use as an indicator to see
how much and um
and that you know because because it's
it definitely was an issue it hurts and
we've got different nerves we've got
different nerves in our body we've got
nerves that are temperature nerves we've
got nerves that are you know if you
prick with a needle that's more of a
pain fiber but we've got stretch nerves
so you know our intestines
we don't have to know if something's
going to focus with a needle but it's
super important if your if your stomach
starts to stretch too much or your colon
stretches so we've got stretch fibers in
our in our intestine
but but when we start to get that
tightness the stretch fibers are
sometimes getting kind of twisted or or
pulled and that's sometimes why it hurts
so part of the reason of going to you
was yes you were referred by my original
doctor in north carolina um i had
already seen you once but i was more
than happy to go to a new doctor if i
had done my research and found that
there was someone else that had rave
reviews however that was still you
and block and and and explains is
something that you in particular have
been doing a lot of so how did that come
about that you ended up doing so many of
them and how long have you been doing so
many of them so i so i've been in
practice for 25 years
when i started my practice
i so i trained at a place where we did a
lot of chest surgery okay so i trained
at mayo clinic in rochester minnesota
and
we were very busy with cardiothoracic
surgery and my program chairman there
was particularly very good nationally
and internationally at chest wall
reconstruction
so so i had a basis there and then when
i started my practice here in scottsdale
i did a lot of breast cancer
reconstruction okay um
which are there's components of the of
and and block capsuleectomy with that so
you know there's um
you're you're using implants or taking
implants out or doing lifts or doing all
those kind of component surgeries to
make people match um
you know i kind of tell people i'm not
your guy for um
15th time nose surgeries in town but i
do a lot of breast surgery and um then
as as times gone by and as breast and
plan illness has become more of a of a
thing in the topic and women have
approached
you know and have the courage to
approach people because they don't feel
well and they're having issues and
they're not sure why they're having
issues and you know could it be their
implant is it something else they don't
know
um
i started to get approached more and
more for those and so and i think it was
kind of a natural
process with that i started i did a lot
of breast surgery so so some of those
patients started to come to me and then
we had good results and we had
you know it's important to make somebody
feel better but it's also important to
have them look
as as good as they can possibly look
yeah so i think there's
anybody can take the implant out but you
also want to take it out so things look
good what would you do if someone wanted
their breast implants out
if they felt okay versus if they didn't
feel okay would you do that differently
yeah so
so just from a terminology standpoint um
capsule again is is the scarred wall
that forms around any
anything that's not you
so if you have an infection you can form
a scarred off area if you have a knee
replacement if you have a heart valve if
you have any anything that's artificial
have your body doesn't know what it is
so it just wants to wall it off and
in a perfect world it's very thin kind
of no big deal scar
as that scar starts to become more and
more involved it can hurt or can be can
hurt and form a capsule
and then take that in the next step if
you if you're having issues where your
body's maybe really not liking that
implant and having maybe symptoms with
breast implant illness or things like
that
it really starts to you get this like
chronic inflammatory response to just
having that device in there
so
capsules the scar
capsule
otomy means i'm cutting the scar so so
you could go in if you just had a firm
breast and do a capsulotomy and just
kind of open things up so it's really
closed then we kind of just open it
again take the implant out is and then
yes and and so the implant manufacturers
actually if you're having issues with
the device they're like hey that's you
know we warranty our device for a
certain period of time
we'll
give you a new device if you want to go
down that road if you're having
forming too much scar tissue you know
too much scar tissue around
again that's not bi that's just that's
just you're you're forming scarborough
i'm not happy with that i like the way
it looks everything's fine
um
it's just getting firm so there's
there's that's a capsulotomy capsule
ectomy means i'm taking out
right
most of the implant you know if i i'm
sorry most of the capsule if i take out
over 50 percent it's technically a
capsuleectomy
total capsule means i'm taking out the
entire thing
and black capsule xm means i'm taking it
out in one piece i'm not i'm not trying
to leave anything behind
i'm not trying to take out half of it
and then take out the other half of it
so even if when you do an n block let's
say
you
there's
the implants exposed or something like
that like you didn't quite maybe get all
the scar tissue would you not be able to
call that an n block or would you still
call that an n block if you still took
it out with
what you said what you did your best to
get if if you're really technically
doing an m block it's coming out in one
piece yeah so so if you if you start to
piecemeal it even if uh
even if it's tissue yeah
then you're you're really doing a total
catholic capsule ectomy not not an end
black okay
okay
so
was my story uncommon
no i i think um you know i think that i
i have a unique position where i'm
probably getting approached more and
more so so it's becoming more and more
common for me sorry i'm probably gonna
make that happen some more but but i
think that um
it i think your story is a little
uncommon in terms of you're you're very
uh you're very fit you're very strong
you saw this rapid decline and so i
think you're seeing
a rapid you know rebound um and i think
you're unique that you're you're an
athlete and you're able to
uh
really you know give your body and
everything you know externally and
internally than it can and that
you mean that i have a hyperbaric
chamber in my bedroom maybe that yeah so
so those things are maybe unique to you
but i think
so i think you i think your your
rebound's a little faster yeah but i
think that it's not my story of your
story is not your story's not uncommon
and i think that i think your your
your openness to share your story maybe
is is unique and and to be applauded you
know because i think a lot of people
may tell a friend but they're not on the
platform to tell people you're telling
yeah i wasn't sure i wanted to but i
think that people
you know i think it's great that you're
willing to do this i think it's great
that it'll give people validate some of
the things they're feeling and that it's
okay and that it's okay to take your
implants out and and it's okay to ask
those questions what do the drug
companies say like i mean what are the
drug companies that make implants make
breast implants we're just talking about
that um what so there's allergen so so
the main companies in the united states
are allergan mentor and sientra they're
they're as uh ideal as another
company but the the main two from a
market share standpoint are kind of
allergan and mental okay and so
i'm guessing they tell you that they're
safe and i'm guessing that you you put
effort in to pick the right companies
and you know
i'm sure that there's those are probably
the majority but like what i'm curious
from your perspective
what
they share with you and what your
in like what your dive is into their
research because it's
it's their research on their product so
so okay so so to go back in time so back
in 1992 remember connie chung yeah okay
so
uh
and again fact check me but there's an
expose
um
david kessler at the time was head of
the fda
and um she she did a story and released
the story and said you know hey
i don't know if these you know implants
may be causing autoimmune disease
and
they had been
kind of grandfathered in from an
approval standpoint
they hadn't had to jump through as many
hoops as
as they
as as other devices may have had to jump
through okay and so at the time so
kessler was like whoa you know maybe
this okay
maybe this is something maybe there is
this autoimmune thing
so they were pulled off the market all
all silicone implants the united states
were pulled off the market now in other
countries
canada
europe um
they were like wait what no
we don't see that so this is just
something going on in the united states
okay and in other countries throughout
the world they're kind of still doing
their thing okay
and so um and so i was in practice
during that time the only way you could
put in silicone implants you could still
put in saline implants but silicone
implants was through
in study investigations okay i actually
had people in my office whose sole job
was just to run the study no you know
because it was that big of a thing if
you were doing you know for breast
cancer reconstruction sure or whatever
any any use of silicone implants
and
they kept doing studies and doing
studies and doing studies and they just
it's easy when you're doing a study to
to find
bad results and then you're like oh okay
this is these are horrible yeah and they
kept doing them and doing them and doing
them and it's it's you got to do a lot
to finally like well we can't we just
can't find any any data that links this
to
to autoimmune disease so they they were
after doing all those studies those
companies were able to put them back on
the market through the fda through
normal channels
and
then over the last
say six seven years five years it's
really ramped up then there's been this
this other issue called
um
breast implant
associated um
alcl or or
a lymphoma-like reaction
that's that's not bi that's been seen
with textured surface implants
so so now
um
i've watched a lot about that it could
cause cancer it causes a lymphoma-like
reaction and and it can be it can people
can actually die from that so
um
they're treated the same way they're
treated with an m-block capsuleectomy
they present differently they don't
present with bii symptoms that it's your
breast all of a sudden one breast
usually gets quite larger and there's
fluid around so so it's a different
thing but it's treated the same way
but because of that some of these
textured surface implants
have been taken off the market yeah okay
and then and then over the last six
seven years bii's come on the forefront
where people are like you know
i i don't have a cancer it's not
anything i just don't feel great yeah
and and i'm not sure why
and i'm seeing a lot of things on social
media that other people yeah show you
know
and so there have been support groups
and and and you know pretty much in
every community yeah in the united
states there's been different support
groups
some plastic surgeons
are more uh hard science driven so they
they if it's not if they can't find a
study they're probably i don't know if i
really buy into that others i think are
willing to say you know what i'm not
sure
but i i've seen people get in
get their implants removed and they
really feel better yeah and i mean
you've seen it i've seen it so do you
believe it it's real i i believe i
believe that there's
um women who i've personally seen over
and over and over again who who you take
their implants out and they feel better
now
you know is
that is no one's the same you know
everybody has different exactly there's
over 100 different symptoms and and and
i'm not the normal case you know like i
mean it's not the norm no and i think
it's a small subset of the population i
think the majority of women do fine with
implants i think it's important to say
you know and and with with all you know
all different biomaterials most people
do fine
but i but i think the one thing i think
i said to you at one point i think it's
naive to think that every human reacts
the same yeah i think there's so many
people have allergies
um
you know people have allergies to
antibiotics yeah right so um we still
use penicillin but i mean penicillin can
kill certain people yeah that doesn't
mean we've we've abandoned the use of
penicillin yeah and and you you can't
you don't know that that someone's going
to have a reaction to an antibiotic
until they've taken it you don't know
they're going to have a reaction to an
to an implant until they've had it in
but i think it's naive to think that
they can't have a reaction
but i think what i what i see when it's
really truthfully implant related
they've done their homework yeah they've
seen doctors they've seen a lot of
doctors sometimes
they still feel lousy yeah and um i i
think then you maybe need to start
refocusing and ask yourself okay
i i've really i've really done my
homework and i've really tried to right
the ship
and and certainly we'd never want to
have someone just jump into surgery
right that wasn't my first thing on the
list either i didn't say first stop
surgery no first stop was pill for me
right
yeah
and then ivs well i mean i mean first
stop for you is like
healthy diet yeah exercise exactly that
doesn't work okay well let's look let's
look at blood let's look at maybe
medication needs to change let's let's
do supplements yep you know what let's
let's let's just get my body so it's
homeopathically better yeah and as
optimized as possible and if that still
doesn't okay now now what exactly
exactly well then what are what are
their options because you know i'm
i don't have a lot so you know getting
them out it doesn't mean that i was i
was not in a situation where i had a lot
of extra tissue or i you know anything
like that and so you know it was a very
simple and straightforward but that's
not the case for all women no so what
are their options for you know making
them look their best
outside of implants so like to your
point i think if you really have breast
implant illness
i
can't promise you you're going to know
better oh yeah i didn't know either
that's why i all of a sudden shared it
because i was like i can't believe i
feel better because i didn't know if i'd
feel better right like you can only know
by doing it right and and so i think
that
that's the thing uh because we don't
know why people are reacting so so we
can't pre-test right but i think that if
you decide if you decide it's the right
move to take the implants out and give
your body a break and just see yeah um
you really need to give it a break and
take the implant out and not put another
implant back in
um you can always do another surgery
down the road if you decide you don't
like the aesthetic look or whatever or
if it didn't change anything you can
always revisit it but you need to give
your body a break
you can do fat transfers so i mean fat
is a really um powerful tool now for
plastic surgeons where we can
you know add volume
back right um and and not all the fat
will stay about seventy five percent
right seventy do they usually do you
usually have to come back at least one
or two more times to kind of
you know balance them or add or it's
really common to use fat transfer for
facial aesthetics or for breast
reconstruction or for this kind of thing
where we're taking something out and
we're trying to you know
reuse you instead of using something
artificial right it's just
you're fat it's not going to cause you
know issues with cancer or otherwise
we're just moving it from point a to
point b
which is kind of plastic surgery 101 you
know is
flaps and and fixing things that are
broken right and and so it's a great way
to to resource some balance without
exposing you to anything that's
artificial i'm glad that there's other
options i think that you know for some
women it's a real thing
and um
you know i'm grateful that you did such
a good job with me so thank you and
thank you for sharing the information
about it i think this will be really
informative for people and give people
information about you know what to look
out for and what to do and in the
meantime
you might get a little more busy with
some explants sorry about that yeah no i
appreciate i appreciate you having me on
and uh i'm really really glad you're
doing well yeah i'm glad i'm glad you're
having a good good result and you're
just feeling good too well you said
yeah take it easy
i'm just out on a little walk because
i have so much energy um it's hard to
convey that in a picture so i thought
i'd just give a little story about it
like i woke up after surgery and i was
walking around and i was like mom i just
have so much energy and for so long i
always did everything i needed to do but
i kind of like efforted for it like i'd
like get myself up i had to
say come on you know and i know how to
try harder so
um so i did now i just feel this natural
energy like instead of feeling like okay
i gotta go do this now i feel like i'm
almost like bubbling with energy like
ready to go do something so
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button